[Music]
[Applause]
let's bring in nick wright the popular
co-host on fox sports ones first things
first before we get to the chiefs
will you miss tom brady
i will
and i don't think he wants to retire and
so i don't think he should
is that
i don't know this is controversial i
guess
but
i think there are pros and cons to
anything in life
and i eat up to it including being the
family of tom brady
i think the pros are obvious and too
many the list the cons might be
that for seven months of the year
your dad is very or your husband is very
focused on one thing
and i think he has earned the right
to
put himself first in that he set a goal
dan there's one goal left that he has
played on 45 he's one year away he's
still obviously good enough
and i feel like he's being pressured by
the people he cares the most about
but i think his kids would get it
like it's certainly when they grow up
like well you know my dad was the
greatest ever at something and i think
as a kid
once you're older you'd be like i hope i
wasn't the reason he stopped playing so
i did you get the impression at all that
he
individually won't stop playing football
because i don't
and i think it kind of sucks that the
best to ever do something isn't getting
to leave on his own terms or
the way a lot of other guys are forced
out because they're not good enough
anymore and i think that'll gnaw at him
i just don't know and and brady made it
official on his instagram that he is
retiring a half hour ago but i i don't
know what is left if you're only playing
because you're going to play to your 45
because you said you were going to play
to your 45 like that's that's not enough
motivation for me to keep going out
there and going yeah i'm 45.
each week hey i'm 44
i mean let me ask you i agree with that
listen i the i am especially after our
last interview you know i was hesitant
to even come on the show but i didn't
want to seem like i was running from the
chief's loss i mean you were mean you
were bullying you was really you know
beneath your standards of broadcasting
so i would not compare you to tom brady
however if we were to expand the sports
broadcasting mount rushmore to you know
eight nine 32 people you have a place on
there somewhere why are you still doing
it
you're old
you're rich
um i guess i have to do it is like a
public service
for for america because there's nobody
who does it like i do as well as i do
and i i think if i step down
can anybody ascend to this right who's
gonna fill that void exactly right and
that's not very carried on the backs of
seton and paulie and fritzi it's gonna
be hard yeah um yeah i mean i do this
for america
you do it for america why did johnny
carson keep doing it why
does you know there are there is an
element of
i just think
that
it is one thing if
you are
like the vast majority of human beings
who live
somewhere between mediocre average above
average right in the meaty middle it's
like my god you know i'm traveling every
weekend i'm never seeing my kids i'm
missing everything at my quest it's
slightly greater than mediocrity
or someone who it is i'm going to retire
before 30 years younger than most people
ever retired 20 years younger i am still
competing at the highest level
my drive is what
has in many ways opened up these doors
my kids will be able to walk through
forever and now i'm stopping early now
the counterpoint to my own argument i
guess is he did happen to marry someone
who was the tom brady of her field and
she walked away 10 years ago so maybe
she's like tommy i already did what
we're asking you to do it just it would
if you if let me ask you this and then
we can do the other stuff i don't mean
to be too probing
but if someone that you really love and
care about
had
pushed you and pushed you to walk away
when from your career when you wanted to
keep going don't you think that would
cause some tension
rift like that would be something that'd
be hard to get over it would be for me
no because that happened at espn
i was i was gonna sign a five-year deal
and that morning my wife said you know
the kids are gonna be out of the house
when this deal is done
she like i didn't i she did me a favor
because you didn't retire no but i came
home
i came home and started something out of
my attic i passed on espn no one does
that but i
thank god i did it because i was missing
everything because i was so focused on
espn
and i
my wife had the clarity to say look
they're going to be all gone and you
have three daughters that need you
and just so you know that but she didn't
say don't don't sign the contract i did
that on my own where i said i'm gonna
they said take it or leave and i said
i'm gonna leave it and then i called her
and i said i'm coming home
she didn't celebrate like you know she
just said great and then i said no i'm
coming home i'm quitting espn
yeah so well then listen i and may and
you and i have talked privately about
you know when you and i got to know each
other it's because you were listening to
my radio show so you could steal your
takes for your radio show because you
have bigger audience i had the better
takes so you would listen to mine at
night and then you'd regurgitate it yeah
um and you you know you and i talked
about
the push and pull of me doing the
mornings and then morning tv and then
evening radio and not being around
whatever it is and i you know and you
talked about hey it's exhausting and i
you know
at some point you got to think about the
work-life balance and i unders but i i
guess the way i look at it maybe i'm
wrong here is he's still a relatively
young man he's not young in sports terms
but he's young in life he's 45 44
and so i don't know i i guess let me put
a pin on it on this
if he if he doesn't play next season
do you think he never plays again
because if that it if you still have
that scrap if you still have that itch
and you don't get to finally like go out
on your own terms i do wonder if he goes
back
no because he's going to be a
businessman that'll scratch the itch
it's not the same every every athlete
who retires always thinks about
god i could have i should have why
didn't i it's really rare when an
athlete retires and goes i don't miss
this at all you know
and i tom will miss that because he
played at such a high level and he knows
that he's still a you know top five
quarterback and would be next year
they're just not going to win a super
bowl next year i think if if he thought
that they would be better
maybe that would be the the thing that
would be the launching point for his
conversation with giselle to say
i can win one more super bowl i don't
think he's confident that tampa bay is
going to be that good and that probably
helped the process as well
no that's fair i mean i think that the
id you know they were they were this
close to hosting the nfc championship
game i think they'd have beaten the
niners like they could have won this
year's i know that they have cap issues
and all those things but when you look
at the quarterback situation in the nfc
i don't think anybody if tom brady
announced that he's coming back what are
the bucks the third favorite to come out
of the nfc rams packers bucks like i
don't think that there are some also ran
some wobegon team i'm not sure i just
that
again it's it's a little awkward to
discuss but at no point did i hear tom
brady ever be like i'm you know what
i've gotten my fill of football i think
and those other guys that want to come
back or didn't want to quit usually okay
that's fine and good but nobody wants
you on the team anymore because you're
not good anymore he just had almost one
mvp this year i don't know
we're talking to nick wright first
things first co-host uh fox sports one i
text you
when the chief's bengals were going into
overtime
yeah and i didn't hear back now i didn't
know obviously what the outcome was
going to be i was just saying i think
the bengals got the chief's attention
that's all i said
no
let's be fair dan because let me hold on
this is gonna take a moment cause i have
to unblock the number and then i can
uh
i think the exact quote if we're gonna
be fair
is quote i think
my bangs have your attention yes end
quote you personalized it not the
bengals of the chief's attention you
made this as a dan patrick versus nick
wright thing which is interesting
because i don't i didn't know you were
but i did it before i'm from cincinnati
and i did this prior to the result the
end result good for you i didn't do it
afterwards what's your point why
couldn't you you didn't do it at
halftime why you certainly didn't do it
when it was 21-3 i wasn't i wasn't
rubbing and you're basically 21. you
could why would you reach out to me when
i'm at my most vulnerable it was just it
was overtime you guys won the toss you
got the greatest quarterback in the game
you guys were gonna blow out the
cincinnati bengals if i recall you
saying i just said hey
i think we got your attention that's all
you got it you could have said yeah boy
they they came back i'm really really
surprised boy they got a lot more grit
than i thought hey dan a nice little
team you got pat my head and then move
on
a lot of things i could have done
instead i ignored you like i wish i
would have fritzy's interview request i
dan i was very upset you reach you know
that i'm
you know i've got thousands of dollars
on the game i've got reputational value
worth you know potentially
earned millions not that much but on the
game couple thousand i've got i i've got
a lot i'm from there
i have a lot of writing on the game and
you
you know
managed to text me when i'm it at my low
lowest
i thought it was rude i thought it was
unbecoming i thought it was bullying
much like our last interview no this was
just to acknowledge that hey you guys
won the toss you got mahomes you're at
home you're probably going to win i just
wanted to put it out there
and just say hey you know what
that was a nice contest and the bengals
they put up a good fight that's all let
me see it do you think i've spent 11
minutes talking about tom brady's
psychology because i was really
interested in it or because i was trying
to avoid this very topic
i know how radio clock clocks work oh i
know i filibustered long enough we would
be like ah we don't have time to get no
i'm gonna blow right through the
commercial break just keep going because
the dynasty of one continues in kansas
city
oh you know what
they made me talk about that on the tv
show this morning this was the question
more likely
dynasty or they never win another super
bowl let me ask you that what do you
think's more likely there
that they'll win another super bowl
thank you of course it is the poor guy
mahomes has one bad half
you know what
he's got one good quarter in two super
bowls he has not played well in afc
title games he hasn't played well ifc
title games
bite your tongue sire i'm sorry the
14-point comeback against the patriots
that that wasn't playing look at his
numbers he doesn't have three touchdowns
no picks hold on i actually have the
numbers without looking at him how did
he do the final two quarters against the
bengals
at home you said no i said one bad half
you then said he hasn't looked good in
afc title games so let's actually go to
the facts something once upon a time you
used to do but evidently you're allergic
to now first afc title game ever against
bill belichick uh 14 points second half
comeback uh takes the lead in the fourth
quarter and then ties the game up with
less than 30 seconds remaining when
getting the ball back with 39 seconds
then next afc championship game uh down
17-7 to the titans comes roaring back
once again three touchdowns no
interception how does he get down all
these times how does he get down
oh i don't know the next day i'll tell
you how he got down the next one next
afc championship game uh before he
touches the ball down nine nothing
thanks to a muffed punt the bill's
getting the ball um a 38-6 run once
again multiple touchdowns no
interceptions then he played poorly for
a hat and how did he play in the super
bowl how did he play in the super bowl
his two super bowls
yeah so let's talk about him first one
the second greatest comeback in super
bowl history seems good i don't know
he had one he made one play it was a
broken coverage on tyreek hill he almost
got beat by jimmy garoppolo
we're doing almost got beat by okay
that's fine no though
you're you're saying he's the greatest
quarterback in the league he almost
yeah well he obviously is especially
brady retiring who's the best
quarterback in football who is it give
me a name well an hour ago it was brady
okay that's great you live in the now
dan we live in the here and the now okay
who is it uh how did how did he do
against the tom brady last year super
bowl okay we live in the here oh and
last year's super bowl yeah i'm just
doing some stats here pressured 29 okay
here's a stat for you take every nfl
game ever played in recorded history
what quarterback was pressured the most
in any single game playoff regular
season uh mahomes in the super bowl so
if you want to put together joe got
sacked nine times a week and a half ago
and won the game
that's correct i like joe burrow let's
go how about we call a different play
how about your your genius andy reed how
about we call something so i don't get
sacked all these times
you want to relitigate last year's super
bowl that's fine we can re-litigate life
you want to talk about conference
championship games how about how about
your beloved tom brady not throw three
picks in every conference championship
game he plays in three second half picks
against the packers somehow escapes that
now now i'm bleeping on tom brady day
you're retired you put me in this
position
threw three picks against the chiefs afc
championship game one of them avoided
thanks to the d4 nonsense this is
out of fingers
right radio don't have any fingers left
for rings i mean come on you can't beat
then well this is i'm arguing stats with
a man that doesn't know tens more than
seven i mean what do you want from me
here uh he actually has three fingers
left buddy i sold you no no no no no
giselle made him cut cut those off oh so
he wouldn't stay here
yeah so he wouldn't stay and say i got
to get rings for every finger
that's great that's called that's called
that's i'm an insider i want the
audience to know something okay
i want the audience to know what
compensated zero dollars for these
appearances
it is on in direct conflict with
very popular programming on my own
network so i probably shouldn't even be
doing that
you won't i've invited you to basketball
i will
you know what i would rather go i don't
want your pity i will i look i will i
will be seen with you i will go out and
let people see and they'll go oh dan
patrick's son man he doesn't look
anything like him
you know what that's another thing he
made fun of my voice last week
the other day not that long ago
um when we were watching as a family
netflix and one of your stupid cameos
came on some stupid movie
uh hey now oh now you're gonna get me
mad you can call me a bad host bad take
bad journalist but i'm a freaking good
actor well not only good actor because
here's the problem when you came on
there i said that's the guy i go on with
you know what my wife said hot my mother
of my children love of my life one who
saved my life
he's handsome for an older fellow she
she's a journalist
she's objective i love that objective i
love that that's great i don't i didn't
love it you know what i said
all
site
are you going to l.a cgi
no i'm not going to l.a
oh
darn it why why you were going to be
there i am i am going to be there yeah
but i'm going to invite me to meet the
crew yes i would have you join us on set
oh okay where's your set right now i'm
just curious connecticut
connecticut where am i right now
you're probably in
brooklyn
i'm in manhattan
again you're always taking little shots
at me well there's a little little
burrow snobbery no no no you invited me
to a next game in brooklyn i thought
maybe you lived in brooklyn no no that's
fine uh no it's because they were in the
playoffs that that's the other thing you
look like i love this living room
again no that's a hipster that's a
hipster that's a hipster oh yeah i'm a
hipster that's a thing um
no but so here's the thing dan this is i
love this dan and i work and live within
i don't know 45 minutes of each other
never see
what are you doing friday night yeah
hanging out with you evidently do you
want to go to dinner friday night
i do okay
are you is that with you or are you just
going to give me a resume make a
reservation in my name maybe like hey
you and your wife should go
uh i was going to take my daughter out
but i didn't know if you would like to
go to dinner in the city
i'm not trying to third wheel it with
you and your daughter okay you're such a
bad guy you give a whole heartfelt my
wife told me i'm gonna miss the kids and
then and then you end it with okay i
guess if you know i was already gonna be
in the city with my daughter you and i
hang out another time dan it's not meant
to be it's not meant to be and i'm not
going to beg
thanks for coming up
again why do i do this no i every time
this is i regret it this is great for
you your profile i mean come on i'm
going to start paying you in crypto okay
how's that
okay yeah that's fine hey solana has
dipped man now's the time i buy it yeah
solana 97 bucks a coin see you buddy hi
thank you nick
bye that's uh that's nick wright first
things first co-host fox sports one you
know i'd love to go to dinner with him
but i got to spend time with the kids i
mean that's what it's all about all
about the kids